I watched a lot of TV at home a lot in
my underwear watching TV and there's a
new product no it really doesn't look
good
here's a new product called that you see
at the snazzy Napper yes it's this is
real it's designed to help you sleep in
public yeah and there's this commercial
warning for this is a real commercial
check it out
while others toss and turn trying to get
comfortable you can rest and relax with
us the snazzy Napper is a comfortable
and cool soft and lightweight sleep and
privacy shield that blocks out
distracting life next door just yeah she
prefers to nap I wish I saw that it's a
real commercial I was shocked that
anyone would make such a horrible
product then I was even more shocked
when I found out this company has
literally been designing sleep products
for decades
there are even worse than this snazzy
Napper this apparently is their good
idea
check out these commercials I found
having trouble catching a few Z's in
public why not paint yourself to sleep
with sleep pain just two and three brush
strokes blocks out distracting white so
you can
can't seem to fall asleep between two
complete strangers try nap gravel
it's like privacy in a bucket sleep
anywhere anytime with our revolutionary
slumber sack and a patented dream hammer
it's like privacy in an airless plastic
bag and also a hammer
[Applause]